I deserve to get her the latest trailer  for the People vs OJ Simpson is here and  it is juicy and I'm not a public  personality I don't know how to do this  Sarah Paulson as Marcia Clark weeps John  Travolta pitches a deal as Robert  Shapiro and David Schwimmer's Robert  Kardashian stops OJ Simpson from  committing suicide not kill yourself in  Kimmy's bedroom give me the gun give me  the gun earlier this year a 20/20 report  claimed the former football Pro  attempted suicide in the childhood  bedroom of Kim Kardashian  her father was OJ's friend and lawyer as  it turns out the moment will play out an  American crime story at a screening show  producers revealed the scene was shot in  the actual home the Kardashians owned in  Encino at the time of the 1995 trial  they even looked at old photos of Kim's  bedroom in order to match the set the  People vs OJ Simpson American crime  story premieres February 2nd on FX  you